字幕: Ayana Nakamae
校正: Shimajiri Michiaki
私は みなさん方には
何を話すのかなという風にして
思われるのかもしれませんけれども
縄文人の神話的世界観
という話をさせていただきます
私たちは 会場の皆様方も
そうですけれども
別に意識することなく
普段は合理的にそして科学的に経済的に
ものを考えているはずです
今日私がお話をするのは
神話的世界です
いうなれば非合理的で非科学的で
非経済的なものの考え方ということです
まさにこれの天才が私たちの祖先である
縄文人だということです
ただ 誤解しないでください
縄文人のものの考え方は
現在の私たちにとっては
何の役にも立たないと
それは縄文人が原始的な人たちで
遅れたものの考え方だと
思ったら大間違いです
実は私たち人類というものは
10万年前から脳は
何も進化していません
ですから最初から私たちは
ホモサピエンス・サピエンス
になったときから
ものの考え方として
合理的にものを考える方法と
私が言う神話的世界観ですね
神話的なものの考え方と
両方ものの考え方をできる
能力を持っているということです
今日のおそらく結論は
うまくいけば私たちは合理的な
ものの考え方だけではなくて
神話的世界観とのバランスをとることが
大事なんだという話になると思います
だから今日は縄文人に
登場いただきます
私の話は一切しません
全て縄文人の話で置き換えたい
という風に思っております
それで早速ですけれども
今日は3つのエピソードを
3つのキーワードを使って
そうしたみなさん方がもう既に
忘れてしまっている神話的世界観が
現代の私たちにも
実はあるんだということを
気づいていただこうと思っています
まず最初のキーワードは
月と水です
みなさん方 まじめに
考えないでください
月は私たちの地球に
水をもたらしているんです
ウソ言いなさいという科学者が
たくさんいたとしたら
そんなことはないという風に
言われるかもしれませんけど
あくまでも神話的にものを考えると
そうなるんです
それが不思議でも何でもないです
じゃあ私たちの生活の中に
そうした月が水をもたらすという感覚が
あるかどうかちょっと見てみましょう
私の大好きなエピソードがあります
今日は時間の関係から
1つだけ紹介しますけれども
神奈川県の足柄群の山北町というところで
おそらく今もやられていると思います
民俗儀礼と言ってしまえば
それで終わりですけれども
あそこでは11月の23夜ですよね
ですから下弦の月の日です
今日は何だかご存じですか
昨日は満月だったんです
今日は満月から1日過ぎた
十六夜（いざよい）ですよね
それは別に置いといて
下弦の月の日に山北町の
若い男女が 若いカップルが
屋根の上に上がります
屋根の上に上がって
お盆にお茶碗を乗っけて
そのお盆を頭の上にのっけて
屋根の上に上がるんです
そんな危険なことと
そう言う話ではないんです
月の水をほしいから上がるんです
でも実際に科学的に考えちゃだめですよ
神話的に考えてください
実際にやってるんですから
月の水をいただいて
カップルですから
要するに赤ちゃんが生まれますように
赤ちゃんが授かりますようにという
俗信だということですよね
こういうことが現代でも
行われていることであります
今日はたった1つの例ですけれども
こんな例は本州に行くとたくさんあります
北海道はちょっと特殊ですよね
150年前に明治政府がここを
開拓してからの歴史ですから
なかなかそういったものに
お目にかかることはできないです
もう1つですね
そうして考えたときに私たちは月が
水をもたらすということだけでなくて
月の満ち欠けも私たちは
見ることができますよね
先ほど満月の話をしましたけれども
月というのは新月を通って
そして二日月 三日月になって
上弦の月になって
満月を経てまた今度は下弦の月になって
最後に三十日月といって
本当に消えゆくような光を出して
また新月 闇の世界を作るわけですよね
そうしたときに私たちはそのことを
今現代の私たちは何もそんな恩恵に
被らないと思っていますけれど
そうではないです
神話的世界の中ではそれは
非常に重要なことなんです
それは私たち人間が唯一生物界の中で
死を予見できる存在だということです
それと同時に死を予見できるばかりに
私たちは誰一人として
死にたいと思う人はいないんです
死なないようにちゃんと脳は
それをプログラムしています
ですから死なないためにあらぬ事を
私たちはやるわけですよね
死にたくないために
それは何かというと
死なないものにすがるということです
そして神話的世界観の中で
世界の誰もがすがったのが
月だということです
それは闇から光
光から闇という風にして
29.5日間で月は循環するからです
それを私たちは死なないものの
存在としたということですよね
2つ目のキーワードは
今度は蛇です
月は確かに先ほどですね
足柄群の山北町の若いカップルが
実践していたように
月は生きるための水をもたらす存在です
だとしたらその水を
運ぶ人が必要なんですよ
それは誰かというと
蛇なんです
みなさん方は蛇が嫌いですよね
誰も蛇好きな人なんかいませんよね
今日私お守りでちゃんと
蛇のお守りを持ってきたんです
これは後で紹介しますけれども
井の頭駅の隣の弁天様で売っていたんです
それは全然関係ないですけれども
そして 私たちは蛇はなぜ
月の水を運ぶ存在かというと
蛇は死なないからです
月も死なないんです
蛇はなぜ死なないかというと
脱皮と冬眠を繰り返すから
古来世界中の人たちは蛇を死なないものの
存在として崇めたてたわけですよね
そうしたことから
現代の私たちの生活の中にも
そうした死なない蛇の恩恵に与ろうとして
いろんな不思議なことをやっているんですよ
まずは神社
神社の中で例えばですよ
水神様とか弁天様
みなさん方はお世話に
なったことがありますかね
最近は何か 鎌倉弁天か何かに行って
お金をざるに入れて洗うと
金持ちになるそうなんですね
最近若い人はキャッシュカードを
洗っているんだそうです
たぶん私は全然
御利益がないと思いますよ
あったらごめんなさいね
でもそれは要するに水の神様なんです
お金の神様ではないんですよ
弁財天だから財を成しているから
お金の神様でもあるのかも
わかんないけれど
それは現代的な 合理的な
ものの考え方です
もともと私たちは古来水を祀るために
神様を置いたわけですよね
その中で1つ面白いところに行ってきました
これは今年です
先ほどもちょっと出しましたけれども
このお守りを買ったところは
東京の杉並区のあの井の頭池です
井の頭池はみなさんご存じですか
あの神田川のあの水源なんです
あそこに行くとですね
神社が3つ祀ってありました
1つは弁財天様でした
このお守りを買ったところです
その弁財天様の横に
宇賀神様がありました
北海道ではまず宇賀神様を
見ることがありません
でも本州に行くと宇賀神様は
たくさんまだまだあります
宇賀神様ってすごいんですよ
顔は翁なんです
翁で身体はぐるぐる巻きにした
蛇なんです
立派な宇賀神様が置いてありまして
私はそれの写真を撮っていたら
するすると若い女性が来て
手を合わせていました
そしてお賽銭を出していました
つまり 私たちの中にはまだまだ
蛇が月の水を持ってくる
月の水というのは特別な水なんです
もちろん私たちが飲んで生きる
ための水でもありますけれども
子どもが授かるための水
でもあるわけですよね
そうしたものをとにかく
あやかりたいとして
手を合わせるということは
私たちは意識していないけれども
自然にそういう行為が
行われているということですよね
もう1つ神社と言えば
締め縄ですよね
みなさまはあまり
気にしたことはないですね
神社の入り口には必ず鳥居があって
鳥居に締め縄が飾られていますよね
今どこにいっても締め縄はただの縄です
ただし古い神社に行くと
これが蛇です
私の知る限り秋田が一番多いです
秋田の古い神社に行くとことごとく
蛇の縄がかけてあります
ちゃんと蛇の顔がつけられてあって
そこに赤いベロまで
つけられているものまであります
これも今年になってちょっと行ってきました
ある人にですね 誘われて
それは世田谷区のですね
東横線の自由が丘駅から歩いてすぐのとこです
奥沢神社というのがありますけれども
あそこの鳥居にかかっているですね
締め縄は最高です
長さが5m20cmだそうです
それでこんな大きな顔がついていまして
私が感動したのは目です
目はちゃんと二重丸ついているんですよ
古来日本では二重丸のことを
みんな蛇の目と言っているんです
ですから お酒の好きな人は
わかりますよね
蛇の目茶碗というのは中に青いですね
線で二重に書いています
蛇の目がそうでしょう
あれも二重の丸がついているんです
ああいうものを見たときに
全部水に関係しているんです
要するに雨の日に蛇の目傘をさすのは
月の水をもらうためなんです
お酒をこうやって飲むときに
蛇の目茶碗を使うのも
ちゃんと月の生きるための水を
でもそれをね理由にして
奥さんを騙してはだめですよ
それはやめてください
それで もう1つですね
今度は神社からみなさんの
ご家庭に入ってみましょう
家庭の中で水道に行ったときに
みなさんがたはまだ
気づいていないと思うんですよ
普段ね 水を出すときに
あそこをなんと言っていますか
え なんで蛇口なんですか
そんな気持ちの悪い
蛇の口から水が出るって書くんです あれ
なぜ じゃあそう言っているのか
っていうことを考えた方がいいです
古来日本ではやっぱり蛇信仰が
根強く残っているわけです
ですから確かに私の知る限り
明治六年くらいにヨーロッパから
水道システムが入ってきたはずです
そのときにヨーロッパと同じドイツから
入ってきたらサハハーンですよね
それからもしイギリスから
入ってきたとしたらタップですよね
そういう名前はつけていないんですよ
みんな蛇なんて名前はついていません
日本だけが蛇の口と書いて蛇口と言って
水と蛇の関係をちゃんと家の中に
持ち込んでいるというわけですよ
そうしたことを考えたとき
更に遡って縄文時代の人たちがどう
考えていたかということも重要です
さあ そこで縄文時代と
いえば縄文土器です
縄文土器というからには
縄文がついているんです
縄文は縄の文と書きます
ところがね おかしなことに
私も含めて縄文土器の縄が何を
意味しているかっていうことは
未だにわかっていません
考古学の教科書を開いても書いていません
ただ私はたまたま去年出した本の中に
そのことを書いてしまったら
完全に考古学者から無視されています
蛇だと書いたんです
蛇に決まっています
一万年間も長きに渡って
縄文人はあの土器に縄の
模様をつけ続けたんです
ファッションだやらデザインだ
と言う人がいますけれども
ファッションやデザインがですね
同じ模様が一万年間続いた模様なんて
ものは世界の中で例を知りません
それは違います
それは明らかに
まさに月の水を呼び込む容器の中に
蛇の模様をつけて月の水を溜めたんです
だとしたら容器はもうわかりましたね
それは子宮だということです
月の水を運んできた蛇がその
運んできた水を入れる入れ物が
まさに子宮だということです
さっきの山北町のですね
あの若いカップルが屋根の上にまで
上がって月の水をもらおうとしたのも
ちゃんと身ごもるようにという
1つのおまじないだったわけですよね
さあ そうして考えたときに
まず3つ目のキーワードは
子宮だということです
みなさん方だんだんちょっと
今日はこいつは怪しいなと思い始めた
んじゃないかと思うんですけれども
決して怪しくはありません
確かに私はですね
日本の考古学会からは無視されています
でも きっとあと20年経ったら
私の時代が来るはずです
（拍手）
すいません それで
みなさん方が納得する話を1つ
エピソードとして入れたいと思います
かまくらです
かまくらはまさにいざ鎌倉のあの鎌倉が
あのかまくらの名前の由来になっています
ですから少なくとも秋田県なんかだと
一番古いかまくらは7百年前ほどに
その記録が残っているんだそうです
まあ一般的には4百年くらい前に
あのかまくらの行事が始まった
といいますけれども
あのかまくらは
なぜ旧正月の満月の日
2月15日の満月の日に
やってるかを考えた方がいいです
真っ白い雪でもって
あのドームを作るわけです
まさにあれはお母さんの子宮なわけです
くり抜いて奥に何を入れると思いますか
水神様です
必ず水神様を祀っています
ただ水神様と言っても
ただの水ではないんです
まさに月からもらった子どもを
育むための水ですから
それは羊水に決まっています
そして今はね この間もちょっと横手市の
かまくらを見てきましたけれども
もうすごく観光資源になってしまいましたから
もうかなりいい加減です
秋田の人がいたらごめんなさいね
というのは中に七輪を
置いていい大人がですね
あそこでビールを飲みながら
焼き肉なんかを焼いているんですよ
あれはだめです
もともとかまくらというのは
あそこに子どもを入れたんです
子どもが戯れる場として
かまくらを作ったんです
羊水を入れてそこに子どもも入れて
子どもはそこから要するに新しい
子どもが生まれるようにという
1つの神事だったわけですよね
そして今はですね横手市でも
かまくらの次の日に
実は梵天祭りをやっています
恐らく私の考えるところ
梵天祭りは昔は同じ日に
やっていたはずです
2月15日の満月の日に要するに月の水を
運ぶ主役が次の日じゃだめなんですよ
その日にかまくらに水神様に水を
運んでこなければいけないということです
ですから今は観光の都合でもって
長い方がいいだろうってことで
たぶんかまくらと それから
梵天祭りを分けたんでしょうけれども
梵天はあの二尺下ろし
のときに使うですね
長い棒の先にぼんぼりをつけたものです
間違いなくあれは蛇
だということですよね
ですからそう考えたときに
今日はこんな話をするつもり
じゃなかったですけれども
江戸の火消しが使っているあのまといも
恐らく梵天と同じ意味を
持っているんじゃないかと思います
物の本には要するに
長屋の延焼を防ぐために
あそこでがんばっているんだと
書いているものもありましたけど
それは嘘です たぶん
間違いなく月の水をもたらしてもらって
火を消すという意味があって梵天を
あの火消しがまといの上でたぶん
盛んに出て振っていたんだと思います
もう1つみなさん方には決定的に
私がいい加減なことを言っていない
という話をしたいと思います
それはダンボール箱です
どうですか
若いお嬢さんも
いらっしゃいますけれども
あなたはついこの間まで
ダンボール箱に入っていませんでしたか？
どうですか
入っていたでしょう
恐らく今日はですね
会場にいらっしゃるみなさん方もみんな
ダンボール箱に入りましたでしょう
ちょっと年配の方も
そちらにいらっしゃいましたんで
ダンボールにどうですか 入りましたか
なぜですか
なぜダンボールに入りました
いや 答えはわからないんです
わからなくていいんです
私たちは無意識のうちに
ダンボールの中に入っているんです
別にお母さんに入れって言われた
わけじゃないわけじゃないでしょう
お父さんに教えられた
わけでもないんですよ
子どもはダンボール それから押し入れ
それから隅っこ ああいうところを
見つけたらとにかく入りたがるんです
それは子宮だからです
私たちは脳の中にちゃんと
それがプログラミングされて
いるんだと私は思います
ですから無意識のうちに
子どものうちは
誰からも何かを馬鹿にされるような
環境がないから子どもはやっぱり
積極的にダンボール箱に入って
お母さんの子宮に入って
私は安らぐんだという気持ちを
満たしているんだということですよね
そういう風に考えれば私たちはこれだけ
科学的な生活をしている
合理的な生活をしている
経済的に豊かだと言っても
結局私たちの脳の中には
まだまだ神話的思考がですね
なくならないでちゃんと残って
いるんだということですよね
さあ それを考えたときに更に遡って
縄文時代の話の中で1つだけお話をします
それはお墓です
お墓も結局みなさん方は
もうわかりましたでしょう
縄文人は約1万年間に渡って死者を
墓穴に埋めてきたんです
世界の考古学者の中で
未だに世界的に見ても
死者を墓穴に埋めることは多いんです
地面に穴を掘ってそこに
死者を埋めるんです
それは全て墓ではなくて
ある意味では死者を再生するための
子宮を作っているんだという風に私は考えています
ちょっと時間がだんだん
なくなって来ましたので
最後になりますけれども
こういったものの考え方は
実は日本だけではなくて
実は外国にもまだまだ
神話的世界観はあるということです
私たちは世界の歴史を考えたときに
ヨーロッパはいち早くですね
合理的なものの考え方
科学的なものの考え方にですね
突入した国ですけれども
それでもそうしたヨーロッパでも
アメリカでもですよ
医科大学はどうですか
お医者さんの大学は
みんなエンブレムは蛇を
使っているではないですか
こんな近代医療が発達しても
人を救うですね
お医者さんだとか製薬会社だとか
そういったところのマークには
ほぼ100%と言ってもいいです
蛇のマークが使われています
日本の医科大学は調べましたけれども
ほぼ ことごとく
蛇のマークを使っています
それは蛇が死なない
ものの存在だからです
それだけ科学が発達したとしても
やはり私たちは最後に
死なないものに頼る
月あるいは水 蛇というものに
頼っているんだということを
私たちは知るべきだと思います
さあ それで時間がちょっと
ないんであれですけれども
ここまできたらやるしかないですよね
（笑）
（拍手）
もう1つね
私が最もですね 先ほどのですね
話にもちょっと涙を流しましたけれども
私は本当にこの話を聞いて泣きましたよ
コロンビアです
タイミングが悪いんですよね
日本は負けちゃいましたよね
コロンビアに
まあ割り引いて聞いて下さい
コロンビアのコビ族という人たちが
1965年にある16歳の少女が
亡くなったときの
お葬式の模様が記録されています
それを見て私はもう驚く以上に
感動してしまいました
そこではお父さんが登場して
お父さんにまつわる若い
人たちが集まってきて
娘さんのために
16歳のお嬢さんのために
墓穴を掘ってくれるんです
そしたら恭しくシャーマンが現れて
そのお嬢さんの遺体を持ち上げて
そしてなんと9回墓の上で入れようと
するけど入れないんです
また入れようとすると入れないんです
最初に16歳のお嬢さんを
持ち上げるときは
お嬢さんそのままの
重さで持ち上げるんです
でも9回それを繰り返していくうちに
操作としてはだんだん軽くなって
いるように持ち上げるんです
そして最後10回目にお嬢さんの遺体を
穴の中に入れるわけですよね
それはもうみなさん
わかりましたでしょう
それはお嬢さんがお腹の中に
入った10ヶ月を遡れば
また生き返るという気持ちがあるから
そういう風な埋め方を
しているというわけです
ですから日本に限らず世界中の人たちが
まさに月 水 蛇というですね
そういった神話的世界観の中で
まだまだ私たちは生きているんだということを
知っていただければと
いうように思います
さあ それで最後になりましたけれども
こうした例でわかりますように
神話的世界観というのは
私たちホモサピエンス・サピエンスの
脳の中に遺伝的にプログラミングされたもの
だという風に私は考えています
だから時空を越えて世界中の人々に
神話的思考に基づいた
実に奇妙で
実に不思議な行動を
とらせているんだと
いう風に私は思っています
ややもすると私たちは
縄文人が原始的で文化的に
遅れた人だという風に思ったり
それから神話的な思考をすると
それは縄文人がなにかしらですね
馬鹿にされたりしますけれども
それは間違いです
縄文人は敢えて合理的な
ものの考え方をしないで
神話的思考をして
暮らそうという風にして
決めた人たちなんです
それも世界の人たちにとっては驚異です
1万年もの間この神話的思考で
ものを考えながら
暮らしてきた人たちということですよね
ところが私たちはいつの頃からか
自然や動物に手をかけ
そして農耕や牧畜を押し進めて
そして合理的で科学的で経済的に
ものを考えることによって
神話的にものを考えることを
何かしら嫌いになっていって
しまったわけですよね
これは大変に悲しいこと
だと私は思っています
私たちが合理的で経済的で
科学的な思考に
頼りすぎているとみなさん思いませんか
その結果どうなったと思います
私は嘆かわしいと思っています
世界中の中で要するに
愚かな戦いをしているのは
私たちがこういった考え方を
とにかくどんどん研ぎ澄ました
結果ではないでしょうか
人間が人間であるためには
合理的思考だけではだめなんです
私は決して合理的思考を否定はしません
それだけだとだめだというんです
神話的な思考と
ちゃんとバランスをとることが
何よりも私たち人類にとっては
必要なことなんだ
ということに
私は気づきました
恐らくこの先人類が滅亡するとしたら
たぶん間違いなく人類が神話的思考を
なくしたときだと私は思っています
かつてですね
ロックシンガーのチャック・ベリーを
ご存じでしょうかね
1950何年だと思いました
彼はあのベートーベンの音楽に
非常に崇高な心を感じて敬意を表して
「ロール・オーバー・ベートーベン」
という曲を作りました
これをカバーしたのがあのビートルズだということは
みなさん
ご存じだと思います
私もこれに習って叫びたいと思います
ロール・オーバー・縄文人
どうもご静聴ありがとうございました
（拍手）